you spending a bit of time with true
Geordie Brian
Free Brian well dude I want to talk
about that because I think he's
converting to Islam did you know that
did you get this is breaking news Brian
is actually converting Davidson is now
Jewish yep and Brian trujody's converted
to US Ryan is converting to Islam yeah
he had to give up the foreskin
did you know that no he's a good price
to pay I imagine he's got a master I
don't know how heavy buddy you know what
I mean yeah Brian do you think Brian's
got a big big full skin yeah yeah this
is all four skills yeah it's just 90
foreskin it's like a soft it's like a
sock with a tennis ball in it shout out
to Brian man yeah so I I thought it was
very interesting because you guys do
these sort of intros to the beginning of
your pods where it's like a a rant like
a bit yeah for maybe a minute or two
minutes
and you guys have said some [ __ ] during
those that I I can't believe gets put on
the internet what was interesting about
watching Brian is he said something that
could have been a bit taken straight out
of one of your intros yeah right
and he got smashed for it gymshark
dropped him PokerStars dropped him got
banned for a while on Twitch yeah
is there like a special button that
people need to be able to press that
lights up and says I'm doing a comedy
bit because he's not a comedian yeah but
he dips in and out of Comedy yeah and
because of that it's like he gets judged
by the same criteria that a normal
Creator does but tries to do the stuff
that comedians do do you know what I
mean it's like people that cross both
thresholds they're kind of they're in a
bit of a tough bind because they're
going to be looked at and it's like well
that wasn't a joke that was actually his
true whatever coming out yeah it almost
benefits every podcaster to do stand up
once
so you can say you're a comedian
so you've got the Canadian card yeah
just do it one time and then say you're
a comedian and then just say more or
less whatever you want because like
Comics were like
how do I say it it's only it's like if
you see somebody dressed in like a
provocative manner right and they're
your school teacher you're like what the
[ __ ] but if you saw like a stripper
dressed in that way you'd be like oh
she's really conservative when she's not
tripping right so I think that's what
it's like being a comedian where it's
like you expect me to say even crazier
[ __ ] so if I made the joke that he made
nobody would give a [ __ ] but I think
with a lot with Brian I think you expect
him to be very serious
like he's serious about a lot of [ __ ]
even though he's [ __ ] hilarious like
he was hilarious on our I don't know if
you saw all right yeah but that
[ __ ] is funny so yeah it's a
shame man it's a shame yeah I wonder how
do you create that kind of protection I
always you know my thing is I'm gonna
ride for the jokes my loyalties to the
jokes I know he was making a joke there
was clear misdirect he was playing off
of stereotypes that we all know exists
and um yeah I thought it was funny I
don't know if he has like a hatred in
his heart for for Muslims I think he is
a hatred it's hard for Andrew Tate do
you know what I'm saying but like if
Andrew take converted to Judaism then he
would have a joke about Jews right yeah
exactly like he'd say open it with like
my Dark Twisted Fantasy or whatever like
he would have something busting balls so
it's not about the religion it's just
about punishing this guy that he doesn't
like um
yeah yeah that's what I would say so
yeah I defend him but I also understand
these Brands they're looking out for
themselves right they don't really care
about him they care about his audience
and then once he becomes too radioactive
for them to make money why are they
going to keep giving him money now he's
got to remember that next time he does
business with a brand because if they
come back later and he continues to have
the biggest show and blows the [ __ ] up
and let's say he becomes you know the
the Rogue I guess maybe he's already the
Rogan of the UK but let's say he is the
biggest [ __ ] platform then Jim shark
could come back and be like hey we'd
really like sponsorship and go [ __ ]
yourself you left me when I was in a
dark time so now I'm not going to
continue to promote your brand so that's
what I would do with him I would just
keep on getting bigger and then remind
every one of those companies ain't [ __ ]
well that was the interesting Insight I
learned from you that a lot of people
believe there is this Grand conspiracy
everybody is Unified together in this
way to try and take people down what you
said it's it's individuals it's
individual actions this guy's got a new
house that he basically can't afford the
mortgage on and a kid that's going to a
new private school and blah blah blah
wife expect a new car every so often
yeah and he goes I'm going to lose my
[ __ ] job yeah the incentives are
aligned for individuals to act in a way
which makes it look like a coordinated
conspiracy from the outside yeah that's
not to say that there aren't [ __ ]
like overlords out there that are trying
to coordinate certain things I'm sure
there are yeah but I do think that the
simplest solution is individual people
terrified about losing their job yeah
looking out for themselves 100 even
even though situations where we think
they're overlords a lot of times is the
people under them doing what they think
the overlords would like
like I remember I used to go there was
like a few like Fox News shows that were
like funny like they were actually funny
shows right and um they would have
comedians on you can kind of say
whatever and I remember going there and
I remember like times like like my
material would like skew a little bit
more conservative I remember reflecting
on going like wait a minute am I just
trying to say the thing that would win
in this environment and I had to check
myself and in that moment I was like oh
wow if I was an employee of this company
of course I'm gonna do the things that I
think my boss likes I'm gonna behave in
a way that you're being influenced just
skewed a tiny little bit we're humans we
like to be rewarded bro is there such a
thing as a joke that goes too far
yeah to everybody everybody's got a
limit but is there such a thing like
objectively as a joke that's too much
could you write a joke that would be so
much that it shouldn't be allowed on the
Internet or it shouldn't be allowed to
be published is it funny
yes no then there's not if it's funny if
everybody's laughing then then no
like you're laughing like I mean that's
the thing I learned in my career is
basically like in order for me to get
away with the most [ __ ] up jokes that
I want to make I got to do it right to
the people I'm talking about
so if I'm doing a joke I don't want to
do any black jokes with no black people
in the room I want there to be black
people in the room and I want to be
doing the joke to them because if
they're laughing you can't be offended
on their behalf and it's usually
white people offended on behalf of
non-white people right but if you see
the black people laughing now you got to
shut up with your offense right so what
I kind of realize that and I'm very
fortunate I got this you know very
diverse audience so I can talk about all
these different things to those people
and it's not just a bunch of white
people in the room making fun of
minorities which feels weird even if the
jokes are funny yes like there could be
a hilarious joke about Asians but if
there's no Asians there it's like all
right what's going on bro doesn't it
feel weird talking about your friend
behind his back while he's not that I
don't even like talking about black [ __ ]
on the podcast without Alex
so Alex one of my co-hosts on flagrant
like when he's there it's way more
comfortable talking about black [ __ ]
right because there's a black dude at
the window into the black world yeah
yeah he could be like okay this is now I
can see why people are upset or if he's
laughing you know that it's silly it's
still kind of fun yeah it just makes it
better yeah I know what I mean or even
gay stuff like without Mark I don't want
to talk about gay [ __ ] do you know what
I mean like he doesn't know he's gay but
he is
you know so that's why Mark is there so
we have some gay representation you know
what I mean just sitting in the middle
of two guys the way he likes it is it
you know what I mean listen you don't
get monkey pox one at a time guys you
know that's a group activity
shout out to the gays right with was
that a thing in England monkey pox uh
um did it come over here
no no it probably didn't no no England
no that just wait yo yo you gays in
England are soft
stepping up
Step It Up New York gays are the hardest
gays on the planet like we have New York
gays
they're okay
they're gay they're gay the way I would
be gay how
dick all the time bro
like like everybody was shocked that
this monkey box thing was like a problem
I don't know if you heard about it yeah
yeah yeah okay okay because the what's
the guy's name fauci fauci basically
came up and he was like
you know the way it's getting
transferred or whatever what did he say
exactly it's like [ __ ] I don't know how
he said he was getting drunk he was
getting transferred through butt sex
yeah but it's a specific type it was gay
orgies
uh yeah exactly okay yeah so you know
stop your orgies I'll do more and then
get immunity natural immunity if you
want I don't care what I'm trying to say
is like the places in the world that
have gay populations that weren't
getting monkey sex I don't think that
you're taking advantage of being gay
[Music]
the canary in your coal mine is have you
got monkey pox on that Canary in a coma
it sounds like some gay [ __ ] bro that's
what I just said okay that's what I mean
that's a good pun when it comes to when
it comes to the brine thing to just like
think about that yeah yeah do you have
stricter rules as your platform grows
or is it just the fact that you're under
more scrutiny I think you just gotta be
funnier
the the rule would be be funnier and
when you're taking those shots make sure
that they but what about outside of that
what about if it's just someone
generally not necessarily a comedian not
trying to make a funny joke online as
your platform grows and there's more
people watch your stuff yeah do you need
to be more careful about the things that
you're saying especially depending on
which like for example I don't tweet
anymore like I get all these like my
drafts are crazy like one day between
the delete oh man one day I don't even
delete it I don't even let it out there
I just type it in so I know the thought
is there and then that [ __ ] goes right
to the Dress if somebody hacks my
Twitter one day someone at Twitter is
going to press the wrong button and
unleash all of your drafts I got to be
on elon's good side I got to stop
talking [ __ ] about Elon bro because
because he could release all my drafts
in other news I've got to tell you about
athletic greens you are not eating in a
fruit and vegetables in your diet and
you know it and this is going to help Dr
Andrew human and Tim Ferriss have been
harping on about it for years and I
always wondered why it is the best green
strength that I've found and I've tried
pretty much everyone it tastes rate and
it gives you nutritional insurance
through 75 vitamins minerals and Whole
Food sourced ingredients in one scoop
that you take every single day if you're
starting the new year looking to give
yourself some good nutritional
improvements this is a great place to
begin and there is a 60-day money-back
guarantee so you can buy it and try it
for 59 days and if you do not like it
they will give you your money back also
you get a Year's free Supply vitamin D
five free travel packs free pots shakers
and that 60 day money back guarantee
head to athleticgreens.com wisdom that's
athleticgreens.com
wisdom what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]